Secretary of State Rex Tillerson says
the u.s. is still interested in a
dialogue with North Korea but it is up
to Kim jong-un to make that happen
thousands of protesters yesterday took
to the streets of Seoul the capital of
South Korea they demanded a peaceful
solution to the nuclear confrontation
with North Korea Ben Tracy is in Seoul
with why demonstrators are also calling
on President Trump to tone down his
rhetoric
Ben good morning a good morning so
people here in Seoul are used to dealing
with the North Korean threat but they're
increasingly worried that this verbal
sparring match between president Trump
and Kim jong-un could eventually lead to
an actual war and they would pay the
price but now it looks like both sides
are trying to find a way to speak a bit
more constructively if North Korea ends
its seemingly endless barrage of missile
tests Washington says it's willing to
negotiate with Pyongyang
especially after kim jeong-hoon decided
to hold off on launching missiles
towards guam we would like to have talks
with him when the time is right when
they show that they are serious serious
about an effort to move toward
denuclearization we have not seen that
yet
all sides seem to be acknowledging the
obvious a war on the Korean Peninsula
would be catastrophic this is the border
between South and North Korea and just
over there North Korea has thousands of
pieces of artillery pointed at the south
it's estimated if they were to unleash
those sixty four thousand people would
die in South Korea in just the first day
the u.s. seems to be backing down from
its demand that North Korea abandon its
weapons program entirely before talks
could begin saying rather that North
Korea needs to freeze its weapons
testing for a period of time there was
some effort I think to recognize North
Korea's security concerns and sort of
meet them halfway john delorean of
international studies at Yonsei
University in Seoul I don't think the
relationship that the North Koreans want
is screaming back and forth but they'll
take that I think Kim jong-un is more
ambitious I think things like a summit
with Donald Trump and the Selphy that
the world is waiting for between these
two extraordinary figures is the kind of
thing that they'd be interested in China
and Russia have floated a plan by which
North Korea would freeze its missile
tests in exchange for the u.s. in South
Korea freezing their joint military
exercises while the US government says
that's a non-starter and those military
exercises will take place as planned
next week here in Seoul Gayle Thank You
Ben Tracy reporting from Seoul